a gigantic construction site part of a
highway set to run 170 kilometers across
Montenegro financed with the help of a 1
billion euro loan from China this
stretch of construction is along the
Terra River part of a unesco world
heritage site some environmental
activists say the decision to build here
was a mistake there had been 18
alternatives in a strategic impact
assessment and why is a great great
question none of these is just
considering that this is UNESCO site and
some other adult alternate we should be
taken Paulette our River
the tower River Gorge is one of the
deepest in Europe the River Basin is a
biosphere reserve the water that flows
from the higher elevations is
crystal-clear environmental activist
Natasha Kovac avec says it's one of the
most ecologically important regions in
Montenegro
it's host for many important speeches
species like trout species otters and
similar so downstream 100 kilometers it
causes a really important impact to the
healthy habitats in this area about a
hundred kilometers downstream is where
the Chinese financed highway will run
directly across a tributary of the Terra
River building on this terrain is
complicated and expensive the activist
believes that the valley route was
chosen because it's the cheapest option
biologist studying the issues say that
the construction project is destroying
the habitat of various fish and plant
species this river is not recognizable
at this place we have 20 pillows of the
bridge that we can see here which are in
the middle of the river bed that's thus
all river is channelized it's altered
and it's destroyed it's all digged up
from the button to the shores and really
it doesn't look at itself and on one
menin biosphere cycle should be up to
4,000 construction workers from China
have been working here during peak
construction phases Chinese companies
are raking in the profits but paying
precious little in tax plus all the
construction materials and equipment
imported from China are exempt from
customs duties kovachev ages
environmental organization employs 15
people their work is supported by
donations as well as some funding from
the European Union while we're filming a
guard pops up and orders us to leave the
area even though we're on a public road
Chinese manager just said that we have
to leave the place because we can take a
photo dattara but we cannot take
recourse of the construction because
this is something that should be
forbidden so we're leaving
site now a local resident shows us some
of the damaged dirt and sand from the
construction site is silting up the
river the fisherman believes the habitat
of the trout that used to be plentiful
in these waters is being destroyed fish
like this the new highway will connect
Montenegro's Adriatic coast to the north
of the country in the capital podgorica
the state-run agency monta put is
responsible for the construction work
the director insists it's all in
accordance with EU standards that we're
on the right path because we want to
develop northern montenegro that helps
the country and europe as a whole the
north of the country is underdeveloped
compared to the south but the north has
enormous potential in the areas of
Industry tourism and energy Muntz is an
anti-corruption watchdog that keeps a
close eye on the Montenegrin government
day on milliwatts is investigating the
financial impact of the billion euro
loan it's a difficult task because the
government is keeping the financial
details under lock and key
Milovan says research shows that
construction contracts to domestic firms
are only going to companies with close
ties to the government
he's also discovered that under the
terms of the loan an arbitration court
in China would have jurisdiction over
any legal disputes and if Montenegro
can't repay the debt in time China would
be able to make collateral claims we
cannot repay the law the Chinese bank
can ask for for example for a Porto bar
or can ask for the some mine with
cocaine asked to construct dance for
hydropower or can ask to take over the
railroad so there is a precondition
which is providing so little
protection for the economic and what's a
state interest of the government innate
Montenegro is a small country with a
population of just over 600,000 the
average income is around 500 euros a
month the chinese loan is worth almost
one-fifth of montenegro's GDP we asked
Monty puts director for his assessment
there are always risks associated with
any construction project the government
investigated these risks in full detail
so we can say that the project won't be
a problem for the Montenegrin budget
it's important to know that every cent
of highway tolls will go into paying
back the loan we believe will be able to
pay it back down to the last cent we
head to an area just south of the
capital where another section of highway
is under construction pitted against a
billion euro project environmental
activists like natasha kabocha which are
very much underdogs but she's determined
to speak out against the lack of
transparency and rampant environmental
destruction issues that we are coming
from the democratic background and we we
will learn to discuss about things
especially when they have this big
impact with the Chinese investor and and
their culture actually it's more about
just straight forwarding and doing
things without of two questions and of
course that it also causes some clashes
and non understanding for the time being
this is still a highway to nowhere
whether the new superhighway will ever
reach neighboring Serbia is very much an
open question
you